[Music]
catch by botch oh what a pass behind the
back for the slam dunk that's the
prettiest picture today from in the
was about space there to get that
[Applause]
with point six to play ironic traded
with his second three of the season in
eight tries ties it point six to play
seven minutes to play
[Applause]
career gaming as playoffs you gamble
she's already rolling
waiting to teach in distress at the
moment
[Applause]
that way they did count that there may
be some new faces here in Miami but
those two certainly have grown
comfortable playing together as Bosch
makes the horse shot flash four three
[Applause]
two on the shot clock for bajjis three
[Applause]
she to the secular poets perceiving
you've been working on it
first of all in this goes for guy 610
taking that spin move to the basket and
then finish
[Applause]
all fake
[Applause]
strong to the rim
he gets a picture both wait turns the
corner behind his back
Bosh for the lead
[Applause]
his third from a step beyond the line of
bosch his eight teeth three-pointer of
the year
is going to read into that growing out
there that celebration
are you trying to get free
[Applause]
with some extraordinary blades at both
ends of the floor one of those defining
games for the heat to come back force
the overtime and force a game seven went
up at you boy Adam left coach you like
that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report